si la última hora en efecto es que quien
acusa a moscú de haber bombardeado una
mezquita en la localidad de marjah
estamos hablando de la ciudad asediada
en el sur de ucrania acelera desde hace
muchos días y que está sufriendo un
dramático bombardeos pues según las
autoridades ucranianas en el momento de
este ataque había 80 civiles entre ellos
ciudadanos turcos dentro de esta
mezquita y por su parte el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de ucrania de
metro culebra hablase de mariupol como
la peor catástrofe humanitaria desde que
empezó el conflicto bélico más de 1.500
civiles perdieron la vida según culeba y
algunos de éstos tuvieron que ser
enterrados en fosas comunes ante la
imposibilidad de darles una sepultura
más digna